Say goodbye to webcam talks and prepare to communicate via hologram.
Microsoft just unveiled a feature it calls "Holoportation" for the HoloLens.
Sergio, let's just do a high five.
It can send a 3D image of a person across the world...
...to interact with someone else in real time.
This is my apprentice, Darth Maul.
It's basically something straight out of Star Wars, except it's not nearly as sleek.
At least not yet.
You have to have Microsoft's bulky augmented reality device...
...strapped to your face to see the holograms.
And you'll also need to be surrounded by special cameras to send an image of yourself.
So, it's not exactly as simple as using a phone or a webcam.
But Microsoft wants it to be as natural as face-to-face communication.
So hey, maybe one day a bunch of holograms will be sitting with you...
...during business meetings in the conference room.
For Newsy, I'm Mikah Sargent.